who would you say was a great Captain so
I'm
when I came up with the Orioles Cal
Ripken was kind of the guy right Calvert
never had a clubhouse maybe he didn't
stand up in front of the team and talk
cow uh would go on the field and expect
you to play the game the way he played
the game and if Cal had a problem with
you he'd pull you aside no one touched
Aaron Dalton Darren Dalton was so far
beyond anybody I ever played with as a
leader Jason baretek was was the captain
in Boston he didn't have Clubhouse
meetings same thing I'm going to show up
and play the game and work this way I
expect you to do the same so it was more
about because to me leadership is two
things one is setting the example for
people to follow number two is getting
people to do things they wouldn't do on
their own leadership is statistically
agnostic in my mind the best leaders I
ever had had nothing Darren Dalton
that's what made him so great
it didn't matter what his batting
average was if there was something he
said he said it and there are a lot of
guys who believe I have to do you know I
was never a leader in the sense I was
always a veteran and I led my pitching
staffs but I was never a clubhouse there
because I didn't play every day I
couldn't tell you what it's like to to
play game seven of the week on a Sunday
Day game when it's 155 in St Louis but I
could pull you aside and talk to you and
tell you and that was what the great
leaders did they knew and same thing
they knew their players there knew he
could call me out so he did and then the
guys he needed to pull aside and take
behind in the back room he did that too
I'll tell you a great story
um a guy that we got you know for
Orlando Cabrera we traded for him he
came over from the Expos I didn't know
him I knew it played against him
um uh we had a guy who a star on the
team uh and you'll you'll probably guess
who he was but he was a Latin player he
didn't dress with the rest of the team
he dressed in the back with the trainers
he did his own thing
one day or right after the trade Orlando
comes over uh and this guy's name is
scratched out of the lineup and now I'm
I'm in the part of the locker room where
this guy dresses and there's hot tubs
then I'm in the hot tub and Orlando
comes back and and this guy looks at
Orlando and says hey Poppy what's up
he's like don't poppy me he's like
what's up he said Your name's not in the
lineup yeah a little tight today he's
like no no
I'm gonna come back here in 20 minutes
if your name's not back in life you and
I are gonna go
who said this to him Orlando Cabrera
said this to this guy said this to the
to the guy who was a star yeah
we're gonna fight I'm here to win a
championship I don't give a [ __ ] what
this other stuff is 20 minutes later his
name was in the lineup that's a leader
huh back to your initial comment about
sometimes if you're a great producer you
might not be a great manager right so
you know different qualifications for
leaders like I'm a big NBA guy I mean I
know Major League Baseball as well NFL
like it you know Michael Jordan Larry
Bird right even recently Steve Nash
Jason Kidd these guys haven't never won
a championship never been to a finals
maybe bird maybe one time but never won
anything but meanwhile you've got Steve
Kerr he was a eighth guy on the bench
right you've got uh well even Phil
Jackson Pat Riley these guys were never
and look at these guys managing the
playoff teams right now you know you had
some basically Seattle Scott was a
backup catcher kind of yeah I played
with Scott you know he he screened
manager as a player Aaron Boone one of
my favorite human beings in the world
not a superstar that amazing hit yeah
but but I'm saying they didn't have
profound outstanding careers of length
Craig Council I think one of the best
managers in the big leagues Bob Melvin
one of my you know these guys are all
and then there's the you know the
Phillies manager you got guys that none
of them are superstars now they'll bring
in the superstars there's bench coaches
or or places but but being a leader
again
to me is statistically agnostic is it
because your skill set doesn't translate
right it's the same thing in the
military you don't have to have the
stripes on your jersey for the guys in
your unit to look to you as a leader
because when the shots start firing
everybody's ducking their heads down the
hole they're looking to one guy and that
generally sometimes that's not the guy
with the most stripes on his shoulder
who would you say Kevin Millar was would
you say he was a the locker room guy
that rallied or was he he was just a uh
he was uh he was the guy who who kept it
light he kept it light yeah because in a
documentary you know it's like hey we
just got to win one we just got to win
one right well I mean and and you know
that was
that was a very different group of guys
I mean we uh we you know the the a lot
of times when people ask me about the
ankle and the and all the things that
went around that I try to explain to
them
I didn't do anything I didn't think the
other 24 guys would have done were they
in my place and and as as you know it's
it's baseball it's a sport and and I
don't want to go to these extremes but
we would take a bullet for each other in
that sense like you play with certain
you're with each other nine months every
hour of every day you get in I you know
you get in fights we got there were
fights in the clubhouse we had some of
the funniest greatest like fisticuff
brawls ever at 2 30 in the morning out
in front of a hotel on the road because
we were drunk and somebody said
something stupid who was the best
brawler who was like the one that just
straight up was always down and was good
so the guy that well I don't Jason
vertek was a guy that I I so I lock her
next to Jason he would love to be naked
and it was embarrassing because he was
you know he was he had like two percent
body fat and he just sat around like put
some clothes on dude all right catch her
right Jason there yeah Captain yeah but
but like Dave Hollins was the toughest
player ever played with by a wide margin
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
thank you